I think the biggest gift that happened
in the last few years to me was was
doing the show Lucifer and being that
character for like six seven years and
going to that same set every time and
time on set was just like Priceless it
is and I think that you know that
certainly took my confidence to a
different place I didn't feel
um uh like I think there there's a lot
of imposter syndrome that happens in
acting I know and and I used to feel
that all the time because you go from
job to job to job to job and every time
you start a job I think my biggest
pressure that I would have on myself is
I just want the other actors in this to
think I'm a good actor yeah and um I I
think I still you know I think every
actor still probably has that yeah but
if you've been if you're going back to a
place repeatedly you lose that um and
you just sort of I don't want to use the
word autop pilot but you go into a a
comfort zone where you know the
character so well that you are not
second guessing any choices is um and
you're just you're just doing and being
which is the perfect state to act in
right but the second you get another
part that's different it starts over
again we had a weird experience actually
on the penultimate season of Lucifer
because I played they asked me to play
my twin brother in it as well um and so
I was you know trying to sort of make
some differences between these
characters um with the small amount of
time that I had to kind I well I gave
him an American dialect um I changed his
physicality slightly um and I remember
like being on the set and I you know all
these people I worked with for 5 years
and then I had to do this character for
the first time and that's when I felt
like the impostor syndrome kicking in
cuz I was like you get the tingle people
are not going to buy this you know lots
of
self-doubt um but thankfully people that
around me that I knew were not judging
me specifically and um I just you know
you just have to go for it in in those
circumstances yeah were you I hadn't
felt like that for a long time really
mhm